[Music]
[Applause]
all right we have one last story I hope
we'll give you all the feels this is
what I'm
liking moving into a new neighborhood
can be a bit unnerving and that's how
one Rhode Island mom felt whenever she
and her family got their new house that
is until the man next door walked over
and introduced himself almost instantly
he became a new member of the family as
they say in honor a grandpa we have
shine on the line right now along with
her daughter Wilson and their neighbor
Paul watching on NBC 10 oh my
gosh oh my
gosh okay I'm gonna leave with you
sharine like more on like how did y'all
meet like he just walked over randomly
so we just brought our first home last
year and Paul came over to introduce
himself and asked my husband if he
needed to borrow a ladder the rest was
history ever since then Paul has been
over for birthdays holidays cookouts
Paul's there I love it well PA oh like
you like to entertain kids
right yep kids say the dest things oh
they have no rules or regulations they
just say whatever there is they really
do say whatever is in their mind just
ask my son anytime I exit my house he's
like oh you're wearing that that's a
choice I'm like okay it's really fun um
but Wilson what's what's one of your
favorite things about having Paul as
neighbor I like when he brings over some
snacks and I like when has fun with
doesn't I like when he takes his teeth
out oh my God Wilson you have my whole
heart you are so adorable oh my gosh it
was so lovely to meet all of you thank
you so much shine Paul and Wilson I'm
liking your post right now thank
you and that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
kind of the Kelly Clarkson show want to
honor truly good neighbors just like all
y'all so they're going to be riding you
a check for a ,000 that's 500 for shine
and 500 for Paul there you
go all right thank y'all so much thank
you to all our guests this hour Jacob a
Lordi Jose Andres Elias Audrey and
Lauren s y'all have a great day and if
it's not try and change
[Music]
it
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home